we've heard that surrey county council
is considering declaring a major
incident for its public services and
that means that key workers in areas
such as the nhs and the police would get
priority access to fuel you show your
card you get uh to the head of the queue
and i'd like to find out what
as a whole our viewers panel thinks on
this
so let me come to the wall
should key workers get access to fuel
over other people can i see those who
agree
that key workers should get priority
over everybody else
hands up please
i can see quite a
i can see a lot of hands going up there
this sounds
yeah this looks like a this looks like a
policy that
uh somebody in government might want to
adopt but let's before we
test that let me come to sharon dillon
on our viewers panel uh and sharon you
work in the nhs
what did you think i think you had your
hand up
yes um i mean i would like to think that
key workers would have priority because
it makes common sense we've got to keep
the country going but remember this
situation wasn't our making
um we didn't ask for this situation and
it is you know it is a direct failing of
the government that we've got at the
moment absolutely direct failing and
they protect responsibility for that i
mean the question i i'm you know i
haven't seen any i haven't seen worries
at the moment no one has come forward
where is boris where why has he not come
forward i mean we're a national crisis
here nhs workers have got enough to cope
with and we should now have to be now
putting our card forward just to get
fuel it's not fair we didn't ask for
this situation and we should not you
know be putting this put
put out there so we've got to do these
things so you know government ministers
got a lot to answer for
and i think we need answers and we need
them quick
and we need a solution sharon i i can't
answer the question about quite where
the prime minister is tonight but i
think we have to imagine that he's
speaking through
the secretary of state uh george eustis
um let's just deal with the immediate
question george eustis
why
can't you give key workers priority it's
clearly something that would be popular
well i can understand why people would
have sympathy for that argument but
actually the real solution uh is to um
calm you know calm the situation down
and get people buying fuel normally
again the truth is that there is no
shortage of fuel we have the same amount
of fuel being produced in refineries in
this country same amount of fuel uh in
uh you know in storage and also delivers
have kept going you know there's been
some shortages what's actually caused
this current issue with cues at filling
stations and filling stations running
out is that there's been a panic buying
episode we saw that during the covet
situation as well we saw on saturday
sales of petrol increased by about 50
percent over norms now it started to
ease down it's now down to about 20
percent above and also people are coming
down and as those who are anxious fill
their tanks we will see this calm down
and the focus of the government is to
try to get things back into normal order
calm people down allow the supply chains
to move but with respect you've been
saying that for
a week and there are two points i think
which are made one is that
there may be enough fuel in the country
as a whole
but a lot of it is in the wrong places
and secondly
people have been driving past petrol
stations which are dry since last week
this hasn't happened until saturday
so you can't really blame the consumers
for this can you well i'm not blaming
the consumer what i'm saying is what
happened is on around thursday of last
week
there were some four courts that
announced that they didn't have enough
distribution to be able to get to all
their forecasts so they closed some of
them it was a very small number uh
overall
that then got widespread coverage in the
media and i don't blame the media that's
what the media do but as a result of
that we then saw you know panic buying
and a surge in demand of 50 that's
what's caused this issue and it's only
really when
just as we saw with the food panic
buying episode early in the pandemics
okay only when we get over that that
things will return to them okay let's
just deal with tonight's issue
do you agree
with what seems to be coming out of
surrey and what clearly
is the
uh view of our viewers panel that key
workers should get priority well it'll
be an individual uh really individual
businesses will will sort of make that
decision when we had issues with food
supply during the pandemic some
retailers chose for instance to have a
an hour at the day where they
prioritized nhs workers uh and the
elderly uh it's possible that some will
choose to do that but you know the focus
of the government is actually to get
enough supplies there so that we don't
have to do that but businesses will be
looking at government and
what they will want to know is if they
decided to do that would the government
feel that that was an okay thing to do
or would the government say this is
another way of winding up the panic
no it's uh it's something that they do
so some are already for instance some uh
petrol garages are already putting a
limit uh on sales or a 30 pound cap on
what can be bought now there's two sides
of that on on the one hand it
potentially makes the petrol they've got
go further and the fuel they've got go
further in a situation where people are
panic bowing but there's also a problem
that it could exacerbate cues and that
people join the queue at one filling
station
on balance i think these things over
complicate things and what we should be
focusing on is um getting people back to
behaving uh normally refueling in a
normal way and making sure that we get
those supplies into that we're leaving
no stone unturned to ensure we can do
that let me come back to you sharon
dylan um secretary of state's
not opposed to but he's pretty lukewar
warm about the idea of key workers
getting priority what do you feel about
that
i mean he's
i mean he said a lot of things at the
end of the day i mean
i mean where's the leadership i mean
where why you know
you all you've stated so far is it's a
media it's that it's it's the customers
taking too much at the end of the day
you know where is your leadership and
where are you stating where do we stand
as key workers are you going to give us
priority yes or no i mean why is he left
to the individual for court to decide
again why can't the government now make
a decision and do something constructive
instead of blaming left everybody else
not actually looking at themselves
because it is their failing we should
not be put in this situation i should
not have this conversation with you
right now but i am because you failed
simple you simply failed
failed the answer uh is to as i said get
the no
but she's saying come on she heard that
she's saying make a decision
tell us that you're in favor or not
don't go don't go missing well what i'm
saying is uh i don't think it's helpful
to over complicate things and what we
should be focused on is making sure that
we get the supplies back in to these
garages and actually get the demand
levels down to normal levels it's
already gone from a 50 increase down to
yesterday it was about 20 percent above
normal levels there's signs that this is
calming down now and that people are
getting back to normal buying habits as
soon as they do uh this situation will
be resolved